facciamo un test chi di voi ha iniziato
un libro e non l'ha mai finito
sulle mani e viene fatto di vedere
adesso che vedo
questo è un classicone
chi di voi si è iscritto in palestra e
dopo due mesi non c'è più andato il si
si si se volete io rialzo tutti e due ma
vedo che sono in ottima compagnia grazie
voglio vedere quanti campioni abbiamo in
sala che dicono di iniziare la dieta e
lunedì ma non si sa di che settimana di
che mezzo di che hanno
benissimo ottimo altro signore e signori
benvenuti a bordo
sono sicuro che siamo tutti d'accordo
che non porterà a termine qualcosa ci
crea un fastidiosissimo senso di disagio
giusto
se inizi una cosa la devi portare a
termine
sei un fannullone nemici mille e noi
conclude una
quante volte ce ne siamo sentite dire
che poi erano delle bombe atomiche sono
nostro autostima
io mi ricordo che quando ero piccolino
le sentivo così tante volte da crederci
rischiavo di rimanerci incastrati in
quelle etichette
che poi potevo anche rendere il perché
lo pensano tutti quanti
eppure spoiler alert oggi sono qui sul
palco per raccontarvi come la tecnica
dell'ato trappole mi ha salvato da un
destino ormai certi
sin da piccolo ho sempre cercato di
evitare impegni responsabilità sacrifici
per me quelle erano lato trappole ato
trappole da evitare come la peste mi
ricordo che mio padre mi ha portato a
giocare a calcio a 8 anni e quando
l'allenatore mi ha chiesto che ruolo
volessi fare io risposto il portiere
perché non si correva
alle superiori invece odiavo così tanto
la matematica da scegliere e linguistico
perché c'era pochissima
all'università e me i miei colleghi non
hanno soprannominato the professionist
perché mi aiutava con qualche
bigliettino di troppo durante gli esami
non ne vada assolutamente fiero né ora
né allora però soprattutto in quel
periodo mi ricordo che tornavo a casa mi
guardo allo specchio con un disagio
perché non mi riconoscevo io sognavo
altre cose mi chiedevo che un uomo e
diventare che persona può essere perché
se continui così
questo è il tuo destino ma io mi ricordo
perfettamente che quando guardavo i
documentari sognavo con i reporter che
viaggiavano all'avventura e scoprivano
posti meravigliosi o quando guardavo i
film con eroi che portavano a termine la
missione contro tutto e contro tutti io
voglio essere come loro io sognavo le
loro vite
però quando ascoltavo gli altri parlare
di me ad iscrizione era molto lontana da
questa è così dovevo cambiare dovevo
rompere con le etichette ma come era
fatto
un pensiero all'incontrario chiesto
quando faccio delle scelte sbagliate
beh quando una scelta quando l'opzione
di fuggire era perché non crearmi un
auto trappola noto trappola fatta da me
che mi espongo a tutte quelle debolezze
che cerco sempre di evitare l'impegno la
costanza e sacrificio
un'idea geniale è così finita
l'università micro la prima trappola
giro del mondo in 365 giorni
voleva girerò bisogno di agire affinché
il mondo mi mettesse nelle condizioni di
reagire volevo essere forgiato dalla
vita un po come avete presente il film
300 leonida viene abbandonato nella
foresta deve cavarsela da solo perché
deve dimostra tutta sparta che lui può
comandare e solo allora può tornare io
lo farò lo stesso volevo viaggiare e
dimostrare a me stesso che potevo
tornare a comandare la mia vita
e così ho fatto
365 giorni in giro per il mondo non vi
sto a dire che ne sono successe di tutti
i colori e ho cercato di crearmi piotto
trappole possibili che poi avevo capito
che sarebbero stati mattoncini che
avrebbero creato l'uomo che aspira ad
essere oggi vi voglio raccontare una di
queste otto trappole forse era più tanti
quella che mi ha cambiato la vita
india calcutta
monastero vipassana
sapete cos'è la meditazione vipassana è
una meditazione molto difficile perché
sono dodici giorni rinchiuso in un
monastero senza contatto visivo con
nessuno senza parlare mangiando due
volte al giorno e senza nessuna
distrazione quindi cellulari libri ma
neanche braccialetti niente meditazione
dura così difficile che il guru prima di
iniziare ci avverte e ci dice il secondo
e il sesto giorno molti di voi
molleranno non parlava proprio così ma
aveva ragione perché al seconda stagione
ero lì mi faceva mai tutto il corpo
perché meritavamo tutto il giorno e vede
una fila di persone che si alza e se ne
va
ecco cavoli puoi andare con loro non ce
la faccio più voglio mollare ma ero
dentro agli 8 trappola e non avrei mai
mollato per niente al mondo perché sin
da subito stava assaporando il piacere
di rispettare i propri impegni tra
quello che mi sta insegnando l'auto
trappola è così rimasto 12 giorni a
meditare senza parlare con nessuno e
senza contatto visivo ma è proprio lì
che ho capito che tipo di vita volevo
capito che la vita era è un gioco è un
gioco che però deve essere preso molto
sul serio e io per prenderla sul serio
avevo deciso che volevo vivere tante
vite in una infatti dopo i 12 mesi di
viaggio sono tornato a casa e ho vissuto
una vita meravigliosa
no no perché alla fine ogni buon
proposito è fatto per essere
riconsiderato e son tornato un po di
giuseppe di prima ma questa volta avevo
in tasca la soluzione l'auto trappola
avevo bisogno però di un accattivante
trappola molto più forte una trappola
che fosse un elettroshock non mi facesse
più tornare indietro alla mia confusione
e così lo individuato nella iron man
sapete cos'è
e il triathlon più difficile al mondo
sono 3.8 km nuoto 180 km di bici e 42 km
corsa impossibile lo so soprattutto per
me
che non ho mai praticato nessuno di
questi sport e chiedero proprio
allergico all'impegno alla costanza al
sacrificio ea perfetto così avrà
imparato era così difficile sapevo che
mollare era era dietro l'angolo che lo
perfezionato perfezionato la tecnica
l'ho resa pubblica
ho creato un canale youtube nel quale
ogni settimana pubblicavo i miei
successi ma anche le mie disfatte tutto
non si poteva varare non c'era via di
fuga
quelle che piacevano tanto a me
iniziamo a pubblicare la mia famiglia mi
seguire gli amici erano curiosi ma poi
centinaia di persone si univano a questa
grande avventura e diventano migliaia e
migliaia e migliaia e l'auto trappola si
perfeziona tra chi stava autoalimentando
di persone che stanno tifando per me io
non potevo più mollare anche se era
difficile era veramente dura ma io non
potevo più mollare non lo potevo fare
per loro e nemmeno per me
e così dopo 365 giorni di allenamenti ce
l'ho fatta ho tagliato il traguardo
della roma e questa foto mi emoziona
tantissimo ancora oggi perché lì per la
prima volta ho visto l'uomo che aspira
ad essere un ragazzo che non ha più
paura delle proprie debolezze anzi le
accetta le affronta e le domina
[Applauso]
grazie
in realtà il momento le presentazioni mi
chiamo giuseppe ho 31 anni e da due anni
fa ci report giro il mondo per
incontrare personaggi straordinari in
tutto il pianeta per fargli una
semplicissima domanda
cos'è per te la felicità
pensate che sono entrato fino alla nasa
per chiedere a luca parmitano in persona
sono andato anche in corea del nord per
capire che la felicità come la intendo
io può essere molto diversa dall'altra
parte il mondo ma è pur sempre felicità
sono stato imbarcato per due mesi sulla
nave dss mediterranee persone che
salvano vite in mare nel mediterraneo
che scappano da torture e da guerre io
ho avuto la fortuna di documentare
queste storie e scoprire che la felicità
per loro è soltanto un desiderio un
sogno
capite bene che in questo momento la mia
vita è scandita da avventure fantastiche
ed e incontri preziosissimi e si ricordo
indietro
mi rendo conto di avercela fatta
sono diventato l'eroe che aspirano ad
essere l'eroe del mio stesso film e lo
spettatore qualcuno mi dicesse sì tutto
l'est ho fatto può essere un reporter no
ho utilizzato le auto trappole per
espormi a tutte le mie debolezze darmi
la possibilità di fallire perché cosa
vuol dire fallire il progetto happiness
poteva essere un fallimento colossale
sotto l'aspetto dei social sotto
l'aspetto dei follower dei like delle
virus ma io non mi stavo misurando con
le metriche dei social
io mi sto misurando solo con me stesso e
più incontri facevo più avventure vivevo
e che volevo e diventa una versione
migliore di me stesso quindi come potevo
fallire è impossibile
io oggi sono
orgogliosissimo e onorato di condividere
con voi la tecnica che pur semplice ma
così efficace che mi ha cambiato la vita
io non ho assolutamente niente di
speciale sulla carta se non
essere speciale come chiunque altro e la
vita abbia un sogno nel cassetto e di
ora di aprirlo quel cassetto perché la
differenza sta soltanto nel fare e io lo
sto facendo bene male io lo sto facendo
sto agendo a ciò che non mi piace ea ciò
che vorrei
oggi vi voglio lasciare con la semplice
domanda
una domanda che spero possa essere la
scintilla che faccia creare la vostra
auto trappola
che donne e uomini
aspirate ad essere
grazie
[Applauso]